[Music]
do we have a jealous relationship I mean
I wouldn't say so I ruined your work
party because I got weird somebody was
touching your leg I stormed out I broke
up with you but then you ruined my
Christmas party is it okay to dance with
other people
well dancing in 2017 seems like it's
twerking
it's working are you okay with me like
grinding on a guy not really no I would
never want to hold you back from like
feeling the music that's a new boundary
that I was not aware of that I'm holding
sacred for you to not rub my Weiner on
girls when I dance with them okay wait
don't rub your Weiner on girl okay we've
literally just said no it's okay to rub
your butt on guys John one year I'm not
rubbing my Weiner on them you're rubbing
your butt on their Weiner that's so
different
what's so online that if it were crossed
you wouldn't forgive me I think lying
about cheating probably it also be
depending on how you feel what that
person cheated on me if you were
slapping around some man me that
probably would be too much for me have
you ever been to a strip club
yeah sadly I used to get dragged to a
strip club on the east side of st. Louis
a lot of my cousin cuz he gets to like
work there no it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't fun I've never been to one
I've almost choked no never I've always
wanted to go there I feel like it'd be
really fun Danielle was in there for
probably five or ten minutes before she
started an hour
it was literally no more than 15 minutes
and you started to tear up and literally
I wept I am pretty excited about it
because you are to watch you get a lap
dance I am more uncomfortable about
receiving one
I'm not necessarily uncomfortable but
like is like gonna be a little
off-putting I think I'm gonna puke
my name is IDO black Nile and I am an
award-winning burlesque performer I'm
Tyler from the Hollywood men I
understand why they might get nervous to
get lap dances in front of each other
however it's all in fun if it's done
right it allows trust and it allows the
couple to create a different type of
bond as dancers to get them warmed up
for their private time later you can go
okay yeah I think I should go first you
go first
[Music]
nice to meet you was it no thanks ease
it that was really weird I don't think
there's anything that can prepare you to
like how close his whole thing it's
gonna be to like your face yeah I felt
like me being here like inhibited your
enjoyment of your lap dance I felt like
me being here did not inhibit your
enjoyment of a lap dance no it probably
made it more because you're really fun
to watch if you wanna get a lap dance
sure go for it try to keep the touching
of dicks against your body to a minimum
I mean how would I feel if you like went
to a male strip club now slightly
different slightly uh definitely I'd be
more happy that I wouldn't be there I
don't think I would want you to do that
no no yes would you be comfortable with
me going strip clubs after this how
often once every three months no once
every three years
I think that we learned a lot about how
we're gonna feel in the future hearing
guys to jealousy
do you think this brought us closer yes
in a way yeah this brought us closer I
think breakup um yes I think it did
bring us closer like I need to touch you
now do you want to try do you only give
it a shot or you want to get in there
I'm gonna get in there you me get in
there and touch it no it's not about
that it's about me oh sorry okay it's
about you sorry
thank ya Wow well look at those things